with whatever money you have for
marketing you must squeeze it and it
must work unbelievably hard to make the
thing happen you can't create growth
without new customers or without having
such a great service that you create
Word of Mouth attention is the number
one
asset we must win on relevance not just
on our subjective opinions of brand and
we must do it at scale so what I would
do today is I would produce as much
content as humanly possible on Tik Tok
Facebook Instagram YouTube Snapchat
Pinterest at scale at the lowest cost
possible which is not at the expense of
the quality of the content and I would
do that and then when I would get the
signals Quant and qual signals I would
then
amplify true consumer insights into more
meaningful and that is the model that I
believe
in I am a first marketing hire for a 75
plus year old building products uh
distributor I have a million in one
different angles that I can play I've
spent the first year and a half building
out infrastructure like brand guidelines
uh new website uh first ever CRM for the
company tons of big projects two-part
question here one how do you view or or
create overall marketing strategies I'm
a oneperson department right now um who
are you trying to reach in this company
by the way is it a B2B business yeah we
primarily work with contractors gc's
building uh professionals uh remodelers
right did you go to school for marketing
no all selftaught I'll tell you what I
asked the brand guidelines that like
like you're going about it very
academic which doesn't bother me that
wasn't like a Raz even though I was an F
student everybody knows it like I'm just
trying to get your framework like they
had no consistency as far as branding
colors logos any of that stuff why
didn't you Gra gravitate towards that is
actually my question you need to Rally
behind something out in the public right
there needs to be a visual identity that
people associate with your brand right
but you're a you're not
Nike you have to win on relevance more
than brand positioning I spend a ton of
time on it I put that together it's like
a one sheater basically if that's what
you're asking it's more about the first
year how long have you been in about a
year and a half so those were just some
of the key initiatives I mean the CRM
was a huge thing integrating that with
our ER P software and IT department on
that building out the website by myself
and completely transferring that over I
just got first phase involved with that
I have seven eight phases 75 plus Pages
yet to build out for that and a content
and an SEO strategy I'm trying to figure
out from a holistic picture ramping up
content by myself I don't need I didn't
even have a a functioning website to
send them to so I had to get some of
those pieces put
in overall picture how would you
approach that and then tactically as a
one-man Department how do I kind of take
the biggest and best fite out of that
Apple um so I assume the organization is
a sales organization are these
individual contractors yeah we're
working with individual contractors and
Contracting businesses and you're
selling direct to them through the
website or no no we we don't have an
e-commerce aspect yet right so the
website is informational that leads to
the phone call or the inquiry it's the
sale it's the lead gen sales engine yep
for now so a couple things first of all
where if anywhere is the content studio
in the world and here's what I mean not
a studio you're delivering Goods after
they phone call you to them right and
then they are working right they're
doing their thing the first thing I
would do is play on people's ego I would
create a program for contractors that
are like the gold standard contractors
that you are anointing as a wholesaler
these 12 to 20 guys and gals as epic at
their craft by being chosen into the
gold standard circle of our distributor
because we think you're the best
contractors we are going to come with
our iPhones AKA I Bryce I'm going to
come with my
iPhone and we're going to actually film
you on job and we're going to give you
that content and we're going to use that
content so what you the way you're going
to create besides SEO which is
absolutely going to be a monster for you
and you've called that out if you're
talking about the question directly that
you're asking me it is pretty crazy how
much you can get out of LinkedIn and
YouTube shorts because of search engine
on YouTube and because of the way
LinkedIn targeting works against
contractors and things of that nature
but you need content I think your
content studio is you picking 12 or 20
customers and flattering them that you
think they're good and going and filming
them for the day so that you can then
post produce it for your content so from
an overall standpoint figure out getting
that whole content engine up and running
content engine is everyone every single
question that every single person is
about to ask me is content engine at the
lowest cost possible
okay yeah it's the answer now there's a
lot of answers after that fine now you
filmed it now what like do you know how
to do a thumbnail the first three
seconds do you understand a LinkedIn
Carousel is PDF versus the do you
understand Facebook Facebook groups like
do you understand your content should
sent to a Facebook group because you can
create virality within it that then
sends to your website like there's a lot
more but like anything in life I don't
know if you know this but your back
issues are really your
feet right yep yeah it's a brain [__]
but it makes so much sense it's your
feet so just like that I talk a lot
about parenting that's pretty
foundational right like like so yes
notice what I did and I did it and went
in detail because it's a unique answer
to your question but it might have
sparked stuff for people in here
thinking about making content for this
business like [__] Studio I got to hire
three
dcks uh-uh here's a way to do it for
free we're going to flatter the people
who already buy from us make them part
of this special Club what we're going to
do is go and fil and we're going to
bring value we're going to film oh by
the way the iPhone is more powerful than
the camera drock the iPhone today is
more powerful than the camera that drock
used starting to film me right so that's
another low cost go
film and so it yeah that's exactly right
brother I'm trying to figure out how to
and by the way there's so much wild [__]
literally you doing fulfillment in your
Warehouse filming that and if you really
know how to ASMR that stuff and do some
other wild stuff they're just wild [__]
that none of us would believe in a
million years would work as business
development or marketing that works
there's somebody in your Warehouse named
Carl that's been here for 29 years who
if you just filmed every day is actually
famous and will drive your whole
business sure so it's thinking about
these angles that you haven't thought
about before
that drive down your cost of creative at
scale filming yourself every day writing
a book becomes the marketing of the book
I filmed me drawing every single be I
got it it's there for the documentary
one day hopefully and this and that but
like I could use it for marketing right
now that'd be a good post for us right
just watch me draw a hangout Hawk so as
the only person in the marketing
department focusing only on content like
don't worry about the balance of
everything else that has to be taken
care of just
try my best to allocate as much time as
possible to that I I think it's a mix
brother I think the way you know like to
your point like like you know you can
build on something that I said that I
felt that was fairly smart and you might
get smarter than me you might be like
wait a minute I'm just going to ask them
to film and we're going to Showcase them
now all of a sudden they're doing
everything you're just you're just
giving them the
cosign right so me to take any more time
up worries no no but what's what's good
about hangout Hawk and what I really
want to do this year is like I want to
go deep like I need my dream of this was
that one thing was said to you that you
took like these are things that everyone
can comp on like I'm a restaurant I need
marketing I'm like film The Kitchen 24
hours a day instead of having a day when
you do
content AI is such a big deal it's
almost a little bit difficult to
actually comprehend when I hear the
number that 90% of the cont content on
the internet in 2 years will be AI
generated I don't dismiss that as crazy
that's how fast this will all happen it
might take a hair longer cuz two years
happens fast and there's a lot of
content out there but that makes sense
to me whether it's 4 years 9 years 99%
of content being AI driven makes sense
cuz the AI is going to be more effective
than the humans and that will just
happen I think the more interesting
question is how different it is for the
businesses here than the creators here
here's why every Creator here can make
content at scale through Ai and not have
to worry about any of the things that
every business has to hear the biggest
conversation that's about to happen with
every business here is who
owns the creative that AI is
generating for example vayer which is
very Progressive we are sending out
emails constantly saying we do not make
AI content for our clients because we're
liable because we have not even begun to
talk about the trademark and copyright
issues of AI right now the most
interesting conversations about AI that
I think are happening is the biggest IP
companies in the world are getting their
litigation set up to sue all the AI
companies all the output for the
creative is coming from
sources so I think there is a major
major storm brewing incorporation land
around AI because I don't think anyone's
going to touch it for a long time until
there's Clarity cuz there's going to be
liability the entrepreneurs aren't going
to be worried about that CU Disney's not
going to sue a tick tocker but Disney's
going to sue Under Armor or by proxy us
or by proxy open AI if the source of how
they made that creative came from
sources of Disney so I think that
there's a lot here this train has left
the station and there's nothing stopping
it yes the creative copyright and
trademark stuff has to be figured out
and it will over the next decade I
actually think that's going to be the
thing that Spurs people realizing why
the blockchain
matters I think the blockchain is going
to be a big winner from AI because I
think a lot of people that own IP are
going to put put the IP on the
blockchain to own providance to then be
able to be us like there's a lot of
multiple Technologies Brewing at the
same time right now I think the other
thing that everyone's going to be blown
away by is how quickly you're going to
use AI in your everyday life you know if
you're paying attention sure some of you
saw some of the plugins that chat GPT is
doing with like food ordering service
like if you didn't see this let me just
explain something to you can you imagine
being able to say to a device like an
Alex
Alexa seven of my friends are coming
over two of them are lactose intolerance
three are completely
eating vegan one loves Tomatoes three
prefer onions can you place an order on
seamless and ship it to us right away
and also email me the ingredients of
every product and you're done and that
happens that is
profound the reason the internet and
everything that is going on in our world
is working working is cuz it makes us
more efficient convenience's King is a
historically important statement in
retail but it plays out in real life
everyone here spends money that they
can't afford on convenience and what
chat GPT and AI is going to do is create
convenience that we have never dreamed
of cuz you're not only getting
information like a search engine you're
getting
action and so I think think you're
barking up the right tree it's going to
profoundly and and I would say this for
everyone here if you are not using AI
tools every day of your life you're
making a huge mistake you've got to
start
training whether you need it or not is
irrelevant you're going to need it and
you're going to interact with it every
day so the faster you're good at it it
was like all the people that you met
along the day like remember when you met
Executives 20 years ago 10 years ago
that still don't even use e email and
they have their like secretary print out
the email like when it felt so weird
that's how not using AI will feel so the
faster you get used to it the better cuz
or all the people that didn't go to the
iPhone cuz they needed to touch the
buttons on the BlackBerry they all
eventually use the iPhone nobody here is
not going to use AI every day all the
time and so you might as well start
learning how to use it
now so I've been for
to um go viral continually with the
kaying business um we have over like 400
million views yeah the content is
obviously so conducive if you were
selling concrete it wouldn't be as easy
yeah part of the the thought process um
you know on my daily work is like how do
I convert more of that to actual
business by taking the content that's
gone viral and slightly tweaking it and
making it the collateral that you
advertise against okay let me say that
one more time for everyone the greatest
thing about organic social right now is
the algorithms are not based anymore on
what they used to be which is like your
followers it's now based on the content
so social for the first 15 years was
more about like email marketing build a
list Market to it get a percentage of
them to do stuff over the last two years
we've are fully in the process of the
tiktock ification of all social kind of
why I invested in Tumblr I invested in
Facebook and Twitter for the email thing
invested in Tumblr for the content thing
meaning the social graph used to be
based on your social network now social
media could actually be called interest
media because it's based on the interest
graph the shed could have 19 followers
on LinkedIn tomorrow and decide it wants
to go and the first post could get a
million views if the post itself was
good so you have affirmation from the
world that they like this video now two
things come to mind one does that
equally mean that they want to buy no
and then two you've got to that part you
can't control the part you can control
is say okay this video got 4 million
views organically on Instagram Tik Tok
YouTube shorts let me now retake that
video and make it much more hard-hitting
I'm going to put a banner at the bottom
that says order now discount this let me
change the copy so taking the viral
creative and turning it into an ad the
viral creative is building brand the ad
is building performance we call this
brand formance right taking something
that's gone well organically and turning
it into a conversion a ticket selling
app ad excuse me
yeah and now I want to talk about one
other thing that I think really
resonates across the board in this room
culture there is an incredible thing
going on right now in the world which
is people have options for a lot of us
that grew up in the ' 80s '90s
even 2000s when we were 22 23 the reason
you know how everyone wants these gen
zers to take [__] jobs it's cuz we did I
get it we didn't have
options we've got to really start
talking about culture in our
organizations how many people here are a
boss and whether they're direct reports
or they have reports underneath them to
their direct reports how many people
here in essence manage over 10 people
raise your hands raise it
high great this is really important I
think we're going through Brew no
different than the technology shift and
the big one was the internet obviously
in the late '90s and now the big one
that's Brewing is blockchain and AI I
believe the biggest shift we're going
through right now as businesses in this
room is even bigger than the Innovation
it's the requirements to be a successful
organization from a culture standpoint
and I know this is on everyone's mind
it's on everyone's mind because people
are dealing with remote work I mean I
would say 50% of my employees that work
remote probably work work 1 hour a day
it's tough we're dealing with that right
we're dealing with what a lot of us de
as
entitlement two days ago there was a Tik
Tok video that went super viral because
a young woman was talking about how
unacceptable it was for her to be
commuting to work that didn't land with
Gen X super well but here's the problem
we can sit here and [__] on the emerging
generation or we can understand the
truth there's a a lot of people in this
room that if they were born in a
different era when they were 22 or 23
would have not chosen a minimum wage job
that sucked they would have just built
their business or their brand Direct on
Tik Tok or LinkedIn or somewhere else
these kids are not lazy they have
options they don't want to make 47,000 a
year doing something they hate they know
they can make 47,000 a year selling
T-shirts because of three viral Tik
toks we not them need need to
adjust we to build huge organizations
need
continuity people are starting to get
other options there's a lot coming there
are people who are going to be able to
write policies in a second that don't
even know this industry by pressing one
button on AI in three years that's
coming I could be in Insurance business
in a week with today's [__] Ai and
I'm saying that obviously a little bit
ad lib but it's not as far off as many
people in this room think well my
institutional knowledge that I've built
my whole life is being
commoditized this is a wild time and I
just highly recommend you take a step
back and think about this not only from
a business leader standpoint but from a
parenting standpoint the world parents
and manages and runs governments and
companies predominantly weaponizing fear
you want to know why everyone's anxious
fear is the currency of our world we're
going to cancel you or shame you we're
going to call you bad we're you're going
to get fired sales teams know those
numbers are up there the whole time
right if you don't hit your number like
think about how you par how many people
here are parents raise your
hands think for a second of the things
that come out of your mouth if you you
better not fear by the way it works in
the short term it works in the short
term the problem is it doesn't work in
the long term it leads to massive
resentment it leads to underperforming
I am stunned literally stunned by how
people have not figured out that nice
guys finish first we've been sold a bag
of
[__] for most of the people in this
room the profit and growth in your
business is not about the first part of
my talk it's about the second yes do I
believe you need better tools I do I
don't even understand how one could
debate it I know why one isn't doing it
because they don't want to have the
financial thing happen this year or next
year the problem is you're digging your
hole deeper so I think that's very easy
to understand for this audience if you
have a half a
brain where your growth is going to be
is continuity and growth of your people
when people are happy they perform
better not when they're scared we have
done an atrocious job in business over
the last 70 years to play a game that is
not sustainable and is about to hit a
Tipping Point because not because
they're entitled and are lazy but
because they have
options what that dude that made fun of
me about buying wine on the internet
didn't understand was buying stuff in
the internet is a better option than
going to the store because what I know
that you know is we pay for time time is
money you know many people here buy
coffee on Postmates and Uber Eats and
pay $13 for a coffee to come to their
house it's [__]
insane but we do it we take an Uber you
know how much money people waste for
convenience and choice you know how many
streaming services you're currently
paying for that you don't
use it's what we do right and so I
highly recommend and I saw so many of
your hands go up which makes me super
happy if you are managing people just
ask yourself simple questions real talk
not delusion do you think they like you
do you make them feel safe because I
promise you what is the train that's
about to hit all of us in the next 5
years is not just Ai blockchain and more
social media advancements it is the
culture within our organizations are
going to be a very big deal I want
everyone to understand as I'm talking I
am not sitting up here talking foofy
foofy Grandma stuff and its feelings and
we're all soft I'm talking about making
[__]
money I'm a
businessman I call my organ ganization
the honey
Empire we will win because we will treat
each other with honey versus vinegar
internally but we're building an empire
that is not a soft word I'm trying to
buy the New York
Jets it's expensive who's a Jets fan in
here raise your hands all right first of
all I [__] love
you yeah it's [__] hard out
here so I've been trying to buy the New
York Jets for the last 35 years mainly
because I don't trust it I want to win a
Super Bowl and I only trust myself to
get it done so thank you
so so when I talk about this part I'm
always worried that the hardcore
business person here is like I'm going
to check out look at my iPhone real
quick while he's talking about this
because this is [__] and I know why
people think it but the data is so clear
actually how many people here like
football and know it a little bit raise
your hands I'll use the analogy if good
good enough good enough cuz I want to
use use it
anyway an offensive line the people that
protect the quarterback the data shows
that if those five guys don't get hurt
in a season and have continuity that the
team massively
overperforms that's how I think about
employees we have long operated and led
with fear which actually leads to lack
of retention more importantly a lot of
you say wait a minute like some of you
are being real with yourself right now
and saying I'm not the greatest but he's
wrong my team's been with you me for a
long time it's because they don't think
they have options your team that is
willing to take your not niceness is
insecure and lacks self-esteem that they
can do it somewhere else and are
underperforming and you're getting a 60%
version of them right now and you think
you're winning because they're still
there all retention is not equal my
friends you want to leave with something
you want to note something down in your
[__] head or in your notepads all
retention on your team is not
equal if your whole team's still there
but you're not setting the tone from the
top they're performing at 60% and your
little bursts of fear every quarter
maybe is creating something a little ARB
but it's just not winning and so yes
what am I saying I'm saying it's time
for all of us to be nicer to our
employees is anybody ready for
that okay you're not ready for
it [__] it do whatever you want
but you must not allow the tension of
today confuse you for everyone who is
really about that entrepreneur or
business life you actually know this is
the time to go on offense if you look at
any growth curve of any business these
are the best times to go on offense when
seemingly people are on defense and they
are on defense offense comes in a lot of
forms to wrap it up one your culture
like you want to win more have a
20-minute coffee with employees all of
them one by one and actually know them a
little bit you'll be stunned what that
will mean for your business allocate the
time to
content you must make a commitment to
this content game it is a big deal and
three complacency meaning eliminate it
you praying that it's not going to
happen doesn't stop it technology and
Innovation is undefeated against our
subjective wants and needs S as
individual humans it doesn't matter that
you didn't like it it happened and it's
happening in a big way and it will
impact this industry in a big way and
for a lot of you if you get on the
treadmill now it won't be as bad to run
the marathon in 5 years I don't need you
to become Steve Jobs I need you to start
dabbling a little bit to protect
yourself from the acceleration of the
next
decade thank
you thank you
[Music]
a